en 1950 le mathématicien alan turing
pose la question les machines peuvent
telles pensées et dans les épisodes
précédents s'est attardé sur la notion
de penser parce que pete a cliqué tout
ça mais le concept le plus facile et le
plus fascinant je pense c'est en fait
celui de machines
aujourd'hui on va se demander ce qu'est
une machine et on va voir que cette
question est peut-être la plus profonde
de tout les mathématiques et qu'elle
conduit à ce qui est peut-être la loi la
plus fondamentale de toute la physique
intuitivement une machine c'est un
machin capable de prendre des bidules et
de les transformer en choses et pour que
la machine puisse faire beaucoup de
trucs différents
il lui faut être capable de transformer
différents bidule en différentes choses
qui correspondent à ces bidules donc ça
en gros c'est ce qu'à une machine
regardons maintenant en détail la
manière dont elles transforment le
bidule à l'instar de ce qu'il se passe
dans une usine à la chaîne ou de ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur d'une cellule les
transformations du bidule sont souvent
une suite d'opérations simpliste alors
en général plusieurs opérations
élémentaires peuvent avoir lieu en même
temps
l'étude d'une opération parallèle ou
concurrentes forme d'ailleurs tout un
champ de recherche appelé
l'algorithmique distribués mais pour
simplifier on peut supposer qu'une
machine ne fait qu'une opération à la
fois on obtient alors une machine
séquentiel une machine séquentiel c'est
un machin qui prend un ou plusieurs
bidule et effectue une suite
d'opérations élémentaire au bidule
jusqu'à ce que les bidules devienne une
chose il est important de garder en tête
que les opérations sont simplistes comme
tourner le vice dans le sens horaire
donner un coup de marteau ou sous des
deux morceaux du bidule et de façon
cruciale
le choix de faire l'un ou l'autre sera
décidée par l'état interne de la machine
et l'état du bidule qui lui est présenté
en 1936 alan turing s'est intéressé aux
machines à calculer
c'est à dire les machines qui transforme
de l'information autrement dit pour les
machine de turing les bidules et les
choses ne sont autres que de
l'information que celle ci soit écrite
en langue française mon langage formel
ou encore in her typiquement l'une des
motivations de turing fut de construire
une machine à qui on fournirait un
théorème approuvé avec des règles
d'inférence logique et des axiomes et
qui transformera tous ces bidules en une
preuve du théorème dans le système
d'actionnement question mieux encore on
pourrait espérer que la machine de
tueries prennent des données
expérimentales et transforme ces données
ont des lois de la physique
qui ont généré ces données puis public
tout ça dans un livre pédagogiquement
expliqué de 500 pages de façon cruciale
pour transformer le bidule en une chose
comme les machines mécaniques dont on à
paris plutôt la machine de turing ne
peut réagir qu'à une information locale
typiquement un symbole du bidule en
fonction du symbole lui et de son état
interne la machine de turing va alors
transformé le symbole en question puis
modifier son état interne avant de
passer au symbole suivant ou de façon
étrange mais très pertinente
la machine de turing peut aussi revenir
aux symboles précédent une troisième
possibilité pour la machine de turing
est alors d'arrêter son calcul de façon
cruciale
chaque opération élémentaire et
simpliste et prédéterminés la machine de
turing est en fait entièrement défini
par la liste de ces opérations
élémentaires qui prennent donc la forme
dans l'état à quand le symbole lui et x
transformer le symbole hellickson un
symbole y transformer l'état a en l'état
paie est passé au symbole suivant slash
précédent slash arrêter le calcul alors
tout ça c'est un peu compliqué mais les
détaillants importent peu ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que turing a su définir
des machins très généraux capable de
traiter l'information de manière
purement mécanique et ça c'est que mais
c'est aussi embêtant il y à une infinité
de machines du coup c'est un peu
compliqué de tout les étudier alors
intuitivement pourra se dire que les
machines de tueries avec plus d'état
interne ou une liste d'opérations
élémentaire plus longue
ils sont du coup plus complexe et plus
intéressante que des machine de turing
avec peu d'état interne qui serait
peut-être trop simpliste de même une
machine qui traite un langage avec plus
de symboles doit intuitivement réagir à
plus de complexité
ce qui ferait d'elle une machine plus
complexe et bien non en 1936 alan turing
prouve à un théorème qui je pense est
l'un des deux théorème les plus
fondamentaux de toutes les mathématiques
ce théorème est la preuve constructive
de l'existence de machines dites
universelles et ça ça veut dire que tu
ring a conçu une machine relativement
simple capable de simuler le
comportement de n'importe quelle autre
machine que tuerie
pour comprendre cela imaginer n'importe
quelle autre machine de turing aussi
sophistiquée et complexe que vous voulez
appelons cette machine macha le machin
sera définie par le langage qui peut
traiter le nombre de ces états interne
et la liste des opérations élémentaires
sauf que tout cela cette définition de
machin n'est autre que de l'information
et on peut donc l'écrire dans tout
langage y compris en langage binaire en
particulier on peut écrire la
description complète du machin dans le
langage de la machine universel de
turing supposons maintenant que vous
vouliez effectuer les calculs de machin
lançait sur des bidules pour effectuer
des choses alors vous pouvez dire à la
machine universel d'effectuer les
calculs de machin sur les bidules et la
machine universel réussira à calculer
les choses incroyables temps quelqu'un
de ton machin peut ainsi être simulés
par la machine universel de turin mieux
encore les étapes de calcul de la
machine universel seront alors
équivalentes ou en termes savants
isomorphe à celle de machin en
particulier le calcul aura été long pour
la machine universelle si et seulement
s'il aura été long pour le machin et je
vous renvoie vers l'excellence vidéo de
thomas sur patience pour en savoir plus
sur la construction le fonctionnement de
la machine universel des tueries bref ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que toute la
complexité de toutes les machines de
turing est plus complexe est en fait
contenus dans la machine universel de
tueries alors la machine universelle
qu'elle imaginait turing ce n'était en
fait pas la seule machine universel et
de façon très contre intuitive il existe
des machines universel étonnamment
simple
à ce jour la machine universelle la plus
simple que l'on connaisse et celles
découvertes par youri rogozine
la machine de rogozine traite et des
langages assis symbole et possède quatre
états interne et du coup la description
complète de la machine universel de
rogozine est une liste de 24 opérations
élémentaires seulement alors 24
opérations ça peut paraître encore
beaucoup mais si on compare ça à la
liste des axiomes de la logique ou des
mathématiques on en fait super super bon
eh oui par opposition des axiomes dans
l'arithmétique de paix à nos dents et
daf s'est il y en a une infinité et
perso je trouve ça complètement fou de
me dire que toute la complexité de
toutes les machines de turing y compris
celles qui font des milliards dé google
ou des googleplex d'état interne est en
fait équivalente
de certaines combinaisons de ces 24
opérations élémentaires la machine de
rogozine est donc bien universel au sens
des machines de tueries mais il ya un
sens selon lequel la machine universel
de rogozine est universel au delà des
machine de turing en effet autour de
1936 deux autres grands génies les
mathématiciens kurt gödel et alonso
church chercheuse aussi à comprendre la
notion de calcul gödel est urgent
inventaire alors les fonctions
généralement récursive et la théorie du
lambda calcule de façon stupéfiante york
et turing prouvèrent que l'e3 approche
différente du calcul étaient
équivalentes et elle semblait aussi
équivalente aux machines à calculer les
plus générale que l'on a construit
physiquement et avec la notion intuitive
d'algorithmes qui datent aidé al
khwarizmi et qui a été formalisée par
les nombreux langages de programmation
inventait depuis et surtout depuis 80
ans que des milliers de milliards de
dollars ont été investis dans les
technologies de l'information
personne n'a su développer des notions
de calcul plus générale les plus
puissantes que celles que turing gödel
et church introduisirent dans les années
trente même la mécanique quantique et
même l'algorithmique quantique reste
dans le cadre de la théorie du calcul de
turing goodell et church et ça ça
amenait church et turing à postuler la
thèse de church tuerie la thèse de
church turin affirme tout simplement la
machine universel de turing les
fonctions généralement récursive de
gödel le land à calcul de church et les
langages de programmation moderne de
basic ou c&a python ou javascript en
passant par rascalou scala tous et
formalisme correspondent à la forme de
calcul la plus générale qui soit
comme l'affirment scott aaronson si vous
réfléchissez suffisamment longtemps
vous finirez par conclure que tout
calcul peut être réalisée par une
machine de turing
et là vous vous dites c'est un autre que
c'est cool tout ça mais c'est vraiment
un truc d'informaticiens sauf que si on
prend au sérieux la thèse de church
turing on voit qu'elle ne porte pas
uniquement sur la notion de calcul elle
parle aussi de ce qui peut ne peut pas
arriver dans notre univers en effet
comment parle thomas de patience dans sa
vidéo sur l'incomplétude il existe des
fonctions mathématiques que les machine
de turing ne peuvent pas calculer du
coup qu'il y avait une structure
physique à l'intérieur de notre univers
capable de calculer ses fonctions
mathématiques alors on aura prouvé que
la thèse de church turing est fausse et
pour l'instant à chaque fois que de
telles structures ont été proposés on a
fini par trouver un bug dans la
structure typiquement la structure a
besoin d'une quantité infinie d'énergie
pour effectuer son calcul et ça bien sûr
ça n'a fait que conforter la thèse de
church turing j'ai bien plus confiance
en la thèse de church turing quand
n'importe quel autre lois de la physique
ah oui par opposition je rappelle que la
mécanique quantique à la relativité
générale sont mutuellement incompatibles
et qu'elles sont même nécessairement
toutes les deux incomplète
quoique terriblement efficace pour
prédire certains phénomènes précis mais
le plus intéressant c'est que la thèse
de church turing a des conséquences
vertigineuse pour commencer c'est la
thèse de torture in hybrid
alors tout le corps humain le cerveau
peuvent être simulés par des machines ce
qui clôt le débat de l'épisode de la
thèse de church turing implique que nous
ne sommes que des machines des machines
sophistiquées et cercles et des machines
malgré tout les machines qui d'après le
théorème de turing peuvent être simulés
par des machines
étonnamment simpliste mais atteste
clôture il ya des conséquences encore
plus étonnante
par exemple on peut montrer que les lois
de newton permettent la construction de
structures physiques qui sont capables
d'effectuer des calculs que les machine
de turing ne peuvent pas faire via une
espèce de paradoxes de zénon et ce avec
une énergie fini les lois de newton sont
donc incompatibles avec la thèse de
church turing est du coup celui qui
croit en la thèse de church turin sera
amené à rejeter les lois de newton
de façon plus générale la thèse de
church turing implique que toute loi de
la physique doit absolument conduire à
des structures uniquement calculable au
sens des machine de turing
et ça ça nous invite à conclure à la
quantification de l'est
pas assez du temps ce que la mécanique
quantique semble avoir proposé à travers
les notions de longueur et de temps de
planck
de même l'interdiction de calcul à la
paradoxale à zénon nous invite à
interdire la concentration d'une
quantité infinie d'énergie en un pont de
l'espace-temps ce que la relativité
générale a conclu via la notion de trou
noir
autrement dit celui qui aurait vraiment
pris au sérieux la thèse de church turin
aurait pu avoir un temps d'avancé
quant à la nature des objets extrême de
la physique mais il ya plus étrange
encore on est capable de construire des
machines universel dans notre univers à
l'instar de votre ordinateur et de vos
téléphones
du coup toutes lois de la physique doit
autoriser tous les calculs imaginables
et ça ça revient à dire que les lois de
la physique doivent être universel au
sens de turing indiens aussi turing
complète c'est à dire que toute machine
de turing doit pouvoir être simulé à
partir des lois de l'univers
autrement dit on peut rejeter toutes les
lois de la physique qui ne sont pas
suffisamment sophistiqué pour être
turing complète mais l inverse si on
prend vraiment au sérieux la thèse de
church tuerie on en vient aussi à la
conclusion que toute loi turine complète
est alors nécessairement une description
complète des lois de l'univers dans le
sens où par universalité cette loi
accompagnée d'une description adéquate
de l'état physique de l'univers
calculera quelque chose d'un discernable
de l'univers autrement dit la thèse de
church turing un pic que des lois
physiques sont valides si et seulement
si elles sont turing complète et en
particulier
ça ce sont des lois fondamentales de
notre univers en fait ce que conclut la
thèse de church turing c'est que puisque
il y a plusieurs machines universel de
turing et puisque ces machines sont du
coup équivalente
la nature exacte de la machine universel
de turing que l'on utilise pour décrire
l'univers importe peu toutes ces lois
fondamentales de la physique sont en
fait isomorphe et il n'y a donc pas lieu
de se demander laquelle est vrai la
thèse de church turing nous invitent à
renoncer à la quête du vrai pour nous
attarder uniquement à des descriptions
qui sont plus utiles ou plus pratique
notamment par exemple en termes de la
longueur de la description nécessaire de
l'état physique de l'univers pour
pouvoir effectuer des prédictions et ça
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'incroyablement profond est fondamental
l'année enfin on a parlé du test de
turing est stéphanois nous demandent
s'il ne suffit pas justement de faire
preuve de rhétorique pour pouvoir passer
le test de turing
pas vraiment un test d'intelligence en
fait le truc c'est que pour passer le
test de turing
oui il faut maîtriser la rhétorique mais
il faut aussi maîtriser le sens de
l'humour le sens commun plein de choses
qui on prend ce germain pour acquis et
dont on a tendance à penser que ce sont
les choses faciles à faire mais le génie
de trang c'est vraiment de se rendre
compte qu'à travers ce test de turing
est bien tous ces aspects qui sont en
fait super difficile à résoudre sont en
fait tester en fait plus généralement
bien souvent quand on pense aux machines
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont dire que
les machines ne sont jamais capable de
faire x x par exemple c'est faire preuve
de rhétorique faire preuve du sens de
l'humour ou ce que vous voulez et en
fait vient généralement résoudre x est
en fait beaucoup plus facile que de
passer le test de turing
par exemple pendant longtemps les gens
se sont dit ah les échecs c'est un truc
vraiment humains et les machines ne sont
jamais battre les humains aux échecs car
en fait on a fini par se rendre compte
que gagner aux échecs contre les humains
c'était bien plus facile que de passer
le test du tueur et ducasse est arrivé
bien avant dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et le génie de turing c'est vraiment de
se rend compte que parmi les tâches que
les humains savent résoudre et 20 de
test de turing c'est peut-être le truc
le plus difficile pour une machine
après quant à savoir si c'est vraiment
un test de intelligents que moi
intelligence est nécessairement floués
chacun sa propre définition à limite ses
environs on s'en fout un petit peu ce
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est que
c'est un problème vraiment très
difficile dont on sait qu'il ya une
structure dans l'univers qui est capable
de le résoudre le cerveau humain est la
grande question d'une certaine manière
c'est de savoir quand est ce qu'on va
réussir à faire faire avec des machines
des trucs dont on sait qu'il ya des
structures déjà dans l'univers des
séries mains capables de les résoudre
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment le
truc fascinant derrière le raisonnement
de tuerie est la raison pour laquelle
son test de turing est vraiment quelque
chose qui vaut le coup on en parle peu
c'est qu'il y en a plusieurs parmi vous
comme hannibal a team qui trouvent que
cette série manque de rigueur et en
effet dès qu'on parle en intelligence
c'est un peu compliqué soit je définis
en termes d'intelligence et 99% d'entre
vous seront pas d'accord parce que
chacun sa propre définition du monde
intelligence en soi et c'est ce que j'ai
fait je pars avec une notion assez floue
d'intelligent et j'en parle de façon
assez floue et l'intérêt c'est que la
plupart d'entre vous ne seront pas
rebutés par la terminologie que
j'utilise
et on peut vraiment se concentrer sur
les questions vraiment fascinante savoir
est ce que le test de turing est
vraiment un test difficile pourquoi ce
qu'il est difficile et en particulier
quels sont les outils qui sont vraiment
indispensables à sa résolution
ça ce sont des questions patiente de la
même façon la suite à cette vidéo vous
pouvez vous dire mais dans une machine
c'est pas ça peut-être que vous allez
trouver une définition qui va pas être
celle de turing et de church et
compagnie mais l'intérêt des
architectures inc compagnie c'est
justement que leur définition a eu
énormément de conséquences pratiques et
correspond aussi un corpus théorique
absolument solide est vraiment
fondamental sans doute même plus
fondamentale que toutes les autres
théories mathématiques comme afc mais
bon ça c'est une opinion personnelle
denis beaudoin fait la remarque que
chercher une information dans 100
milliards de livres en fête c'est
quelque chose de très facile surtout si
l'information est bien ordonné et en
effet on peut alors piqué la recherche
par dichotomie or la recherche par des
coteaux mis en gros c'est ce que vous
faites quand on cherchait un mot dans le
dictionnaire vous retirer ou un peu au
milieu du dictionnaire comme les mots
dans le dictionnaire sont ordonnés par
ordre alphabétique
vous savez si le mot que vous cherchez
est à gauche ou à droite ou si la drogue
par exemple vous regardez un parti à
droite du dictionnaire vous couper au
milieu ça fait deux parties et comme
c'est encore par ordre alphabétique vous
savez si le mot se trouve à gauche ou à
droite et vous continuez comme ça par
diviser par deux la taille du
dictionnaire à chercher et cette
recherche est extrêmement rapide elle a
un temps de calcul qu'on appelle
logarithmique sans gros quasiment
instantanée et du coup ça permet de
trouver une information dans son
milliard de livres en temps instantanée
un peu comme lorsque vous faites une
recherche sur google il ya un peu des
algorithmes et six mineurs qui sont
utilisés par google pour que la réponse
à votre requête soit en temps quasi
immédiat alors qu'il ya des milliards de
milliards de pages web
et que à priori chercher à travers
toutes ces pages web pour devrait
prendre un temps très très long y
compris pour les serveurs de google
bien sûr le problème c'est pas alors
sont à 100 milliards de livres c'est
lorsqu'on en a 10 puissance 100 et en
particulier difficultés de discussions
sans livre c'est que ça ne tient même
pas dans tout l'univers observable à ce
moment là il faut absolument une
compression de ses livres et a de très
bonnes chances pour que cette
compression détruisent un peu le l'ordre
lexicographique dans l'ordre
alphabétique dans lequel les données
étaient structurés et du coup ça nous
empêche de faire une renault recherche
par dichotomie à l'intérieur du bordel
c'est pour ça que l'extraction
d'informations à partir de ce modèle
compressé il comme le vous l'imaginez
fera pas un livre un truc gigaoctets
plus chercher une information dans ce
bordel sachant qu'il est pas ordonnée là
par contre ça risque de prendre beaucoup
de temps
une façon de farce a ride serait de le
décompresser et puis d'aller chercher
l'information mais alors décompresser ce
truc c'est leur calcul et du coût
calculé dispensant bits d'information ce
qui je prends un temps beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop longs
sachant que nos ordinateurs de fond que
dispensent neuf opérations de par
seconde bref l'argument c'est que
quelque part dans ce processus il va y
avoir des opérations qui sont assez
sophistiqués qui sont difficiles à
décrire on n'a jamais réussi à décrire
et que peut-être que d'une certaine
manière la seule façon de faire consiste
à traduire les mots ou les phrases en
leur sémantique dans un espace de
sémantique et ensuite manipuler quelque
chose dans cette sémantique pour trouver
une réponse et ensuite retransformer la
sémantique en démon alors dit comme ça
ça peut paraître être de la magie noire
et jamais faisable dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
mais en fait on y est déjà de plus en
plus il ya un truc qui s'appelle world
check qui a été développé par des
chercheurs un google
2012 est presque vide et aux états est
ce que j'ai fait sur le sujet weeds et
c'est justement de passer de la
représentation des mots avec des lettres
comme on les connaît à quelque chose de
plus abstrait qui correspond à ce qu'on
appelle un vecteur d'un espace de grande
dimension et il ya des arguments pour
dire que ce qui se passe dans notre
cerveau correspond aussi à ce genre de
transformation
on passe d'une certaine manière de la
syntaxique à quelque chose qui était il
ya beaucoup plus proche de ce qu'on peut
comprendre intuitivement comme étant dus
à sémantique et le plus fou c'est que le
31 octobre 2017 ils ne font pas donc
très récemment
s'ils l'ont fait c'est qu'ils sont
donnés à lire à une ia qui avec
connaissez rien à la base le vous donner
à lire plein de textes en anglais puis
l'on donné à lire plein de textes en
français mais des textes en français qui
n'étaient pas des traductions des textes
en anglais et à chaque fois il ya a
construit une représentation sémantique
en gros des mots en anglais une
empreinte en sémantique des mots en
français et le plus surprenant c'est que
elle a réussi à combiner juste la
sémantique pour pouvoir ensuite faire
une traduction de l'anglais au français
donc cette ia absolument stupéfiante a
appris à traduire entre deux langues
sans aucun exemple de traduction c'est
vraiment stupéfiant ce qu'ils ont fait
et ça montre je pense que les ja
d'aujourd'hui sont déjà capables de
manipuler un petit bout de sémantique ce
qui est vraiment difficile avec la
sémantique c'est que la sémantique d'un
mossawa sémantique d'une fois a déjà
c'est plus compliqué la sémantique d'un
paragraphe aujourd'hui on sait pas faire
et un ca sémantique de tout un livre de
tout un texte tout un article ça par
contre n'est pas du tout c'est vraiment
très compliqué et j'ai envie de dire
pour le joueur on sera capable d'affairé
la sémantique de tout un texte de tout
un livre
ce jour là c'est une joie on sera
capable de passer le test de turing
bref un truc sur lequel j'ai vraiment
envie d'insister c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui la recherche on ira
avance très très très vite et grands
étaient stupéfaits avec cet article
deux autres choses qui m'ont super fait
cours des dernières semaines après avoir
sorti ma première vidéo sur l'ia est en
gros moi qui ai tendance à lorsque je
parle à quelqu'un les gens pensent
toujours que je surestime les progrès en
intelligence artificielle et en
technologie en général
moi qui du coup à cause des interactions
avec les autres personnes pensent que je
suis restimuler les ja en fait au cours
du dernier mois et notamment après la
recherche les faits pour le premier
épisode de cette série
je suis juste stupéfait je suis surpris
à quel point ça va vite et je me rends
compte qu'en fait je m'aime moi dont mes
amis disent que je surestime
les progrès en iran je me suis rendu
compte au cours des armes qu'en fait je
sous-estiment les progrès on y va et que
ça vraiment encore plus vite que ce que
je croyais bref si vous dis tout ça
c'est parce que je pense que les ja vont
avoir un impact énorme sur nos sociétés
et qu'il est très très très très très
largement sous-estimé cet impact par la
plupart des citoyens
et ça ça m'amène à vous parler de la
consultation publique qui a organisé
cette aiguille lagny sur un site web
toujours mais le lien en description on
peut faire des propositions publiques et
du coup je me suis permis n'est de
mettre deux propositions publiques et je
vous invite vraiment à aller voir et à
donner votre avis y mettre des petits
pouces parce que jusque-là des votes on
joueurs 50 ou 60 pouces bleuse bas
énorme ce qui me ferait vraiment plaisir
c'est de défoncer un petit peu c'est le
pouce bleu sur la consultation publique
de vie l'année passée a beaucoup plus
est vraiment cité sur le fait que les
cias un truc qui approchent et les
progrès sont phénoménaux et qui sont
très sous-estimées par la plupart
d'entre nous voilà vous êtes pas du tout
obligé d'être d'accord avec moi mais je
pense que c'est une discussion qui est
utile à avoir du coup ça me ferait
vraiment plaisir si vous pouviez aller y
jeter un oeil
enfin patience et chaînon manquant sorte
la situation sur laquelle tout ira qui
serait capable de passer le test de
turing serait suffisamment intelligente
pour échouer aux tests de turenne
d'ailleurs cette question est un peu
l'idée sur laquelle l'ia ne voudrais pas
que l'on sache qu'elle a passé le test
de turing et du coup il à la question un
peu de soi fonction du style qu'est ce
qu'elle veut vraiment ces tirs et en
particulier sous jacent cette hypothèse
on sous-entend aussi que l'ia ne veut
pas être éteintes ou quelque chose comme
ça elle ne pas être détruite et ça c'est
vraiment pas dit que les ja et cet
objectif à travers noir désir qui serait
contente qu'on était en train de dire
qu'il suffit de programmer ça c'est pas
aussi facile que ça mais il suffit
d'essayer de donner envie aux saisies à
d'accomplir leur job et est trop content
d'avoir bouclé leur job et ensuite on
les laisse s'éteindre sans problème si
c'est le cas il y aurait pas de problème
parce qu'on attend je pense à introd
powar flize et les ja et l imaginer que
et vouloir conquérir le monde comme
en fait c'est pas dit que ce soit le cas
ça dépend des abonnés intérêts sont
programmés et je pense que beaucoup
justement de réflexion à faire autour de
la fonction objective de lire et on y
reviendra
mais sur ce sujet précis en fait il ya
de la recherche en irak et soheil ayari
safety où on se pose la question de
comment construire des ira qui ne rompt
pas de problème à être éteint c'est ce
qu'on appelle le problème de la safe
menteur au petit bidon qui avait un
papier assez connu de google sky et une
vidéo de comptes twitter file sur le
sujet et récemment j'ai des collègues de
bureau qui sont pas très bons d'ici qui
ont publié un peu d'articles anip sleeps
conférence en intelligence artificielle
qui est par justement de l'interrupteur
bilité d intelligence artificielle
notamment dans un contexte où il ya
plusieurs intelligence artificielle qui
interagissent les unes avec les autres
on peut changer des trucs ça reprenait
un peu plus compliqué et déjà une vidéo
sur wayne dida qui explique ça vite fait
mais il y aura des interviews plus
longue peut-être janvier février
mais en tout cas ce sera sur la chaîne
et à batz de le pfl en anglais pour ceux
qui veulent en savoir plus
elle espère qu'ils avaient aimé cet
épisode la prochaine fois on va parler
de l'émergence de l'intelligence comme
étant juste un processus de calcul et du
coup on va essayer de retravailler notre
intuition de qu'est-ce qu'une
intelligence et comment elle peut
émerger à partir d'un processus purement
mécanique est purement prédéfinis ça
paraît à cette contrainte il dit comme
ça mais wes edouard que en fait c'est
peut-être comme ça que ça marche
vraiment si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le lac est le commentaire
partagé pense à vous avez n'est pas en
tuant épisode merci au team apollo redon
et j'espère que vous serez là les
prochaines fois ok donc la machine de
turing est bien lancée théorique de
l'ordinateur mais lorsque turing fond de
son concept il n'a pas du tout pour idée
de créer un ordinateur
ces machines sont avant tout pour lui un
objet mathématique donc il va se servir
dans ses recherches
à cette époque turing travail sur le
concept d'un des sites habilités watts
m
[Musique]